fast gedacht und herzlich willkommen zum
zweiten part von meinem geld experiment
muss erst mal sagen heute 17 grad und es
ist heiß ich dachte es mal ein pulli an
aber ich schon wieder hier in meinem
büro ist einfach immer warm ich weiß
nicht warum wo fangen wir an weil dieser
ersten partie schon noch nicht gesehen
habt müsst ihr den ersten abdecken weil
sonst macht das hier alles keinen sinn
erster link in der video beschreibung
ich gebe euch kurzen update dies bisher
so liegen wir haben verkauft einmal
diese mini kräftig 38 euro zu bekommen
dann den krieg maker da habe ich 310
euro für bekommen eigentlich habe ich
die kamera ausland verkauft für 880 euro
irgendwie wollte der die dann plötzlich
doch nicht mehr haben weswegen ich die
jetzt noch verkaufen musste ja noch das
samsung-tablet was ich auch noch
verkaufen muss und ja ich muss mir jetzt
erst mal schaffen weil sonst brauche ich
gar nicht weitermachen aber wir kriegen
das schon hin sie locker weg ich muss
sagen ich habe jetzt nicht die größten
hoffnungen drin aber wir fanden es mal
so zwei drei jahren verkauft stationen
ab und fragen nach ob die dort haben
wollen die kamera werde ich aber selbst
bei 850 euro verkaufen und das tablet
eigentlich auch nicht unter 400 euro ist
trotz dem safe gute preise ich bin mal
gespannt aber ins auto los gehts dann
wenn ihr nichts mehr von dem platz
verpasste dann abonniert den kanal
so leute ich bin jetzt im auto ich habe
hier in meinem rucksack immer die kamera
drin plus dann noch das tablet und das
versuche ich jetzt mal irgendwann mal
an- und verkauf händler an zu drehen ich
weiß erst mal zu einem der ist hier in
der nähe wenn er das sich nimmt häufig
noch einen an der iss in bielefeld das
ist schon ein stückchen ob sie überhaupt
interesse hat weil sonst das gar nicht
hinzufahren ich bin echt gespannt was
daraus wird weil ich hab so was einfach
noch nie gemacht schauen wir mal wie
viele leute ich bin da ich versuche mein
glück aber ich glaube irgendwie das
sieht nicht so aus als würden die mehr
sie eine kamera von euro abkaufen
okay das war irgendwie gespendet man nur
und das ist für so umhänge zumindest ein
bisschen leid aber wenn ich mal wieder
das haupt kleidung dann bring ich
hierhin ist ganz anders aus so leicht
nicht aber sucht da ist jetzt so ein
laden da habe ich schon mehr hoffnung
vielleicht klappt's ja da ich bin
gespannt jetzt
[Musik]
hier für
380 und hier für
[Musik]
850 euro
was nicht nur maximal geforderten
das haben wir 40 jährigen mit 100
gewinnt deutlich
120 bäume
ist ein
problem aber dann trotzdem
ich bin mir draußen aus dem zweiten
laden der garde dubios der typen ohne
scheiß dieses tablet kostet über 500
euro ich sagte mir geht mit 380 das wäre
ja schon 120 euro weniger okay ich kann
verstehen wenn er damit nichts anfangen
kann aber auch sonst kann ich es ja auch
einfach bei ebay reintun und dann krieg
ich mir so versteht ja ich rufe jetzt
noch mal bei dem laden in bielefeld an
aber ich bin mir sicher ist jetzt hier
einfach nicht lohnen also reißt einfach
das schlauste das selber über ebay zu
verkaufen das war so nur jedes gespräch
gerade typ der hat mich gar nicht ernst
genommen hat mich direkt aus gelacht als
ich gesagt habe ja dass kosten
9800 ist doch gute preis- oder nicht
naja wir sehen uns ich habe versucht das
tablet über ebay kleineres hang zur
verfügung da wieder abgeben ohne witz
ich werde die ganze zeit von
irgendwelchen betrügern angeschrieben
das ist super ich habe das für 400 euro
eingestellt er wollte mir sogar 430
geben haben schreibt dagegen wie ich
habe gerade die zahlung paper getätigt
bitte überprüft ihren e mail post sein
und irgendwie sbm fällt und ich habe
heute einfach kein geld erhalten unter
dem schreiben wir die ganze zeit so
komische accounts
ist das alter also es läuft leider noch
nicht so ganz rund
[Musik]
heute was geht kleines update diesmal es
ist einiges passiert ich glaube das
letzte mal für dieses projekt habe ich
gefilmt vor sechs oder sieben tagen also
ich halte die sachen verkaufen wollte an
diese an und verkauf leben das habe ich
versucht hat ja überhaupt nicht geklappt
als freier auf jeden fall habe ich dann
einfach mal ebay kleinanzeigen
ausprobiert sonst habe ich immer über
ebay verkauft aber da gibst du halt echt
prozent danni verb und das ist manchmal
echt toll wenn du sachen für acht euro
verkaufen gerade ich sicher ich meine
zehn prozent sind da immer fällig dann
habe ich die kamera das tablet und
diesen krieg maker bei ebay
kleinanzeigen reingestellt und direkt
kamen so anfragen von so komischen fake
accounts das tablet habe ich aber
ziemlich schnell verkauft die sind krieg
und maker auch da kam die bg vorbei ich
kam mir aus der nähe ist angefahren mit
dem auto 100 dass sie gekauft 290 euro
glaube ich hätte auch mehr bekommen
können aber egal es war dann weg und ja
das handwerk und ich habe mich gefreut
habe ich für findet euren verkauften
auch schon und die kamera habe ich an
jemanden verkauft über ecken an niemand
nach köln der da halt video grafik mäßig
unterwegs ist schlussendlich dann für
750 euro ach so und das hat er sich eine
zuschauerin gemeldet die hat mir 38 euro
gezahlt dieses andere ding was da noch
drin war also insgesamt habe ich
ungefähr ich hab's mal ausgerechnet 478
euro gewinn gemacht an diesem paket was
in ordnung ist theoretisch könnte ich
direkt noch eins kaufen aber jetzt
machen wir weiter ich habe das auch
schon gemacht und zwar weil das mit ebay
quellen zeigen einfach so gut geklappt
hat ich hatte zu hause noch einige
produkte von places oder irgendwas was
ich damals mal gekauft habe womit ich
nichts mehr anfangen kann und die
brauche ich jetzt auch einfach alle die
legen eloro mich war zeitig auf jeden
fall auch mal nach hause meine wohnung
und da machen wir so einen kassensturz
ich werde euch alles für euch dann zeige
ich auch noch was ich mit dem letzten
youtube-video verdient hat weil das ja
auch alles rein läuft aber wir laden auf
jeden fall schon auf über 3.000 euro was
ganz gut ist was ich jetzt auch noch vor
hab ich zeige euch jetzt einfach mal
einige der sachen die ich noch verkaufen
werde hier haben wir einen saugroboter
den hab ich vor 2018 der war auch zwei
jahre in unserer wohnung in köln aktiv
ist auch an sich ein super teil ich habe
mir jetzt hier neue und zwar von activex
sie finde ich noch besser und ich habe
halt einem büro und ein zu hause in
meiner wohnung und einen dritten habe
ich jetzt auch verkauft das war einer
der war schon echt alt für den hab ich
aber sogar aus 300 euro bekommen also es
kann jetzt noch mal und auch dann habe
ich hier in meinem lager noch ein ich
weiß gar nicht wo ich den er habe ohne
scheiß kein plant der stand bei meinen
eltern da werde ich auch nicht mehr viel
zu bekommen aber ich denke 50 bis 70
euro drin und das nehme ich auf jeden
fall mit dann habe ich noch ein paar
spiele gefunden und viel sonne drohne
aber das lohnt sich nicht also die werde
ich nicht verkaufen genau da setze ich
mich jetzt 82 noch loswerden und dann
werden wir alles mal zusammenrechnen und
schauen wie es weitergehen wird aber an
sich bin ich schon mal halbwegs
zufrieden okay leute machen wenn man
kleinen kassensturz ich habe jetzt
jemand konnte ich habe das ganze nochmal
auf ein anderes konto über transferiert
aber das ist jetzt all das was ich schon
auf dem konto ab was auch ja zu diesem
projekt gehört und zwar liegen jetzt
gerade
2564 eur 35 eigentlich müsste es ein
bisschen mehr sein ist das auf jeden
fall jetzt hier eingeblendet ok
2564 eur 35 da kommt jetzt noch zu 290
euro von wickie die bg für diesen krieg
maker bezahlt hat die hab ich nämlich
noch in meinem portemonnaie ok plus 290
so wollen wir schon mal bei
2.850 euro 35 lust dann jetzt noch die
youtube einnahmen die auch noch dazu
kommen da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt ich
hab da noch nicht wirklich denke mal ist
es irgendwas also das video hat jetzt
nicht so viele hits aber es müsste 200
300 euro denke ich man so ein ihr könnt
sie jetzt mal schätzen ich kann es ja
auch gerne zeigen warte mal ab fünf
sekunden zeit schreibt sich die
kommentare fünf vier drei zwei eins und
wir haben hier 200 120 euro 63 für das
video war ist in ordnung das kommt auch
noch obendrauf am endlos
223 euro
63 und natürlich kommt da auch hin und
wieder noch ein bisschen merkel zu immer
schon mal bei 3077 euro jetzt habe ich
noch einen weiteren saugroboter verkauf
von früher den habe ich 150 euro
verkauft auch schon wieder über ebay und
einen will ich noch verkaufen bei 75
oder für 70 glaube ich wenn ich dann
auch noch verkaufen sind dabei knapp
3300 euro jetzt nach dem zweiten video
das ist eigentlich schon mal ganz gut
also wir haben jetzt schnell schon mal
auf jeden fall einiges an plus gemacht
weil es natürlich noch nicht so der big
step dabei aber im zweiten video kann
man damit schon arbeiten nicht überlegen
jetzt was ich da mitmache eventuell
kaufe ich einfach wieder was von saturn
weil das war ganz gut ich habe das für
eineinhalb mal schauen was da passieren
wird im nächsten part ihr könnt gerne
sehen indem ihr einfach den kanal
abonniert ich hoffe euch gefällt das
projekt und wir schauen hat wie lange es
noch dauert aber ich bin bis jetzt ganz
zufrieden drei leute